so hi there my name is dr nicole
navroski
and today i will be talking to you about
the use of massively parallel sequencing
in forensic dna typing what will the
future hold
just to start off i want to take a step
back and
just remind everybody that the current
gold standard of forensic biology or
forensic science
is str genotyping um
or forensic dna typing using strs
in order to generate that dna profile
that is used in court
and so we exploit the variability in
strs
in order to really capture those
differences between
individuals in order to make those dna
profiles as useful as possible
in the courtroom for comparing between
individuals
and evidence etc
so what are strs first and foremost
they are found within the human genome
and they're often referred to as
microsatellites
we know them to be very highly
polymorphic or diverse
genetic markers and that's very useful
for the forensic sciences
because that allows us to really exploit
their diversity to identify differences
within
and between individuals how strs are
composed
they are composed of repeat units
between two and seven nucleotides and
you can see that at the bottom of the
screen
where different repeat units come
together
and they vary in length so these repeat
units
are repeated in tandem
either two or more times in order to
create this variability that we utilize
in forensic genetics and so that's
pictured in the top image
strs or short tandem repeats are further
defined by their actual motif
and so there are three primary
definitions
for the motif they can be simple where
it's that same
repeat motif in tandem over and over
pictured here is the tcta motif
repeated over and over they can be
compound where there is one difference
in the nucleotide sequence so that's
illustrated
in the example here with the a being
substituted by a g
and then reverting back to the a
nucleotide
or they can be complex where the motif
is quite variable at
throughout the repeat region and so the
example here you can see
there is the tcta it transitions to tctg
it then introduces a micro variant of tc
goes back to tcta introduces another
micro variant tca
and then goes back to tcta again so
again
very complex in terms of how that actual
repeat region
is defined and we know that not only can
the repeat region be
diverse but the flanking region or the
dna sequence outside
of the repeat region can also have a
little bit of variability
in terms of its nucleotide sequence that
further enhances the diversity
or that heterozygosity of the alleles
looking at the overall picture of
forensic dna typing or str genotyping
there are three main components the
biology
the technology and the application so
within the biology we have that crime
scene evidence coming into the lab
and you're going to perform a dna
extraction in order to get the dna
from the biological evidence from there
dna quantitation takes place and this is
used to generate or estimate the total
quantity of dna in your sample
and then pcr amplification of those strs
so we know that we're looking for
particular regions in the dna
and we use primers in order to focus in
on those regions
and then amplify them up or copy them in
order to have a very robust sample to
test
using technology so in str genotyping we
use capillary electrophoresis
and that takes that pcr product and
separates it by size
through a capillary in order to give us
a result
this result is our dna profile or our
genotype for that particular location
we determine the two allele
determinations
for a particular individual that gives
rise to the genotype
and we look at all of the genotypes for
all of the locations of
interest to get our dna profile from
there we can take that dna profile
or the genotypes at individual dna
locations
and compare it from our dna profile of
interest
back to other dna profiles either in the
database
or in the case file etc in order to
generate conclusions
for our our case
looking at the typical dna profile we
have a profile presented here
you can see at the top of each row there
are names
those names are designated to the
particular dna locations
in the human genome so you can see in
the top row we have d3
d1 d2 d10 etc
in the second row in green d1 d18
etc and um you can see that multiple
locations of the dna were captured
each dna location will have one or two
peaks for a single source
sample meaning that it originates from
one individual
and the reason why it will have one or
two peaks is that an individual will
either have
two of the same allele or two unique
alleles at each location
remembering from basic genetics that you
inherit one copy of the dna from mom
and one copy of your dna from dad you
have the potential to have this same
copy inherited from both parents or
different copies inherited from both
parents
and so here for the heterozygote in the
green
channel you can see that the alleles
inherited from each parent are different
presenting as two peaks and in the red
channel you can see that the alleles
inherited from each parent are the same
length
and so they present as one peak
remembering that pcrce
or the polymerase chain reaction coupled
with capillary electrophoresis
is taking advantage of the length of the
dna fragment
because it's migrating through that
capillary and separating by
size or length of the fragment and so
those lengths appear
as peaks in our electropherogram
which we refer to as our visual dna
profile
we can then take these generated dna
profiles
after they've been analyzed and use them
for comparison
so here we have two suspects and the
evidentiary dna profile
for three locations of the dna d3 vwa
and fga
and you can see that we can use those
peaks or those
length-based genotype determinations to
make comparisons
between the three profiles you can
generate an
inclusion when the peaks
are concordant from one profile to
another
or you can make an exclusion when the
peaks from one profile to another are
discordant
so here you have the evidence on the
bottom
and you can see that all of the peaks
are concordant with suspect two
but are discordant in many instances
with suspect one
so from here you would potentially move
forward with suspect two
as being included as a potential suspect
for that case that you're analyzing
and you could potentially at this point
say that suspect one is
excluded so using this dna profile
information it can be very powerful to
infer
relationships between the evidentiary
profiles
so that was just a quick explanation of
the forensic genetics
dna profiling or dna typing process
we know that most crime labs currently
use pcrce to amplify and separate out
those
strs we generate those dna profiles and
we perform the necessary comparisons and
apply the appropriate statistics
to our findings however we have to
realize that there are several
limitations using this approach
first and foremost individuals can have
the same length
based allele and they can have the same
length based genotype at a given locus
we know that the str information that
we're capturing
is both the repeat region and the
flanking region because of that primer
placement outside of the
region but we're not taking advantage of
that information
we really are only defining our alleles
in terms
of their repeat length
so allele 9 refers to a 9 repeat
length-based allele and we know that
when individuals do
share alleles that mixtures can be quite
complicated
because of that allele sharing and so
our interpretation abilities become
severely impeded when any type of allele
sharing
occurs at a location or at multiple
locations in the dna profile
so an alternative to ce is
massively parallel sequencing it is
considered to be a high throughput
approach to dna sequencing
and it's also commonly referred to as
next generation sequencing in the
literature
and why it has potential to improve upon
our current
gold standard or our current pcrce
methods
is that it generates a lot of dna using
a relatively comparable or minimal
amount of dna
input and what happens essentially with
the mps or the massively parallel
sequencing workflow
is that you're sequencing a large number
of genomic targets so
many locations of the dna simultaneously
for many individuals
in one single reaction and you end up
with a
large amount of dna data at the end of
the sequencing reaction
and you can apply mps or massively
parallel sequencing
to the same types of markers that pcr ce
is commonly utilized for
so we can look at those amplicons or
those small fragments of dna
that we need to look at for forensic dna
typing
so looking at the overview or the
overall
workflow of forensic dna typing using
using mps
it's very similar to pcrc so you still
have those
same biology steps the extraction the
quantification
and the amplification of our targets of
interest
but then instead of using capillary
electrophoresis
you'll perform a series of library
preparation steps and then perform
the massively parallel sequencing again
you'll end up with a genotype
that you will then characterize generate
that dna profile and use for comparison
to your other profiles the database and
then generate your statistics
so many similarities between our
traditional workflow but just
really capturing that additional dna
data in the technology step
to visualize what i mean i presented you
with the picture on the screen
so while we know that pcrce utilizes
only length and presents as a peak
in that electro electrophorogram or that
visualized dna profile
massively parallel sequencing allows you
to look at the actual sequence
which is shown here so here we have
a length-based allele 12 and you can see
the repeat region is blocked off in
purple
and you can see the 12 alleles but you
can also see with the purple arrow
that there is variation in that repeat
region changing the allele 12 from being
one allele to now two alleles because
there are two
possible explanations from a sequence
based approach to account for that
repeat region
and then if you go further out to the
orange arrow you can see that there's
flanking
flanking region information taking that
original
length-based allele 12 from one to now
three possibilities
so mps really allows you to enhance your
knowledge
about the allele at every location that
you're looking at
so what exactly is sequence variation so
i've shown you a picture but that
doesn't really tell you what it is
we're really talking about any
difference in nucleotide sequence
in the amplicon or dna sequence of
interest
so it can be a single snip or single
nucleotide polymorphism
difference here the example goes from
an a to t or it can be a repeat
difference
where the snips have manifested in a
different combination
from one original
motif structure to a new structure so
here the repeat difference
is for an allele length base 7 where it
goes tcta2
tcta tctg3
tcta2 to now tcta 1
tctg4 tcta2
and so you can see that the combination
of that motif has
changed even though the pattern is still
the same
taking that a step further and why this
is really valuable for our
interpretation
is that if you have an individual that
has
a 1415 allele using capillary
electrophoresis you're going to see the
1415 peak
demonstrated on the right side of the
screen
and so the 14 allele is simply a 14 the
15 allele is simply a 15.
but if you introduce any type of
sequence variation
for either the 14 or the 15 that now
increases the diversity of those
alleles so for example here we have
three potential motifs for the 14
and five potential motifs for the 15
allele
and to take that a step further if you
had two
individuals who were both 14 15 by
length
but one of them had at least
one difference in their nucleotide
sequence at that location
for those alleles you would now go from
those
two individuals having the same genotype
by length to now having unique
genotypes by sequence and that's
extremely
useful from a power of discrimination
standpoint and from an interpretation
standpoint
for identifying who contributed those
alleles
to the dna evidence in question
again taking that one step further
and looking at a dna mixture not
knowing that the two individuals are
heterozygous 1415
you're presented with their mixed dna
profile
so on the left using pcrce you would get
the 1415
peaks and you wouldn't necessarily know
how the two component contributors
gave their alleles to this mixture
profile so
you could have various explanations for
example
melissa and marie the two individuals in
question were both heterozygous
contributing 1415
they were both homozygous one
contributing the 1414
one contributing the 1515 or
some variability where one was
heterozygous and the other was
homozygous
really looking at the totality of the
dna profile to understand
how each individual contributed their
dna to that mixture
in contrast massively parallel
sequencing because of the
informativeness in that sequence
diversity then allows you to
make an elimination of one possibility
and to better understand
the quantitative nature of the profile
so here we can eliminate that both
melissa and marie were homozygous
simply because we know that that no
longer holds true
based on the sequence data and we also
gain some information
about how the alleles are quantified in
that mixture
again potentially eliminating additional
possibilities
so what we know is that massively
parallel sequencing is a promising
technology for forensic genetics
and that we will be able to gain a
substantial amount
of str variation knowledge using this
approach
so i just want to spend the next few
slides talking
about a characterization study that was
conducted to look at
our commonly used strs to understand
how sequence diversity can be of use in
forensic genetics
so we looked at sequence variation for
59
strs 27 autosomal seven x
strs and 25 y chromosome strs
and this included all of the coracotis
loci
we performed this characterization study
in 777 individuals across four
major population groups and we utilized
the forensic
library preparation kit in combination
with the mysqq fgx forensic genomic
system
and we performed testing or our analyses
using both the manufacturer software as
well as a variety of in-house tools
the main goals of this study were really
to examine
what sequence diversity existed in the
commonly used strs
and how significant the sequence
diversity was
further we wanted to understand the
differences between the repeat region
and the flanking region
sequence diversity and how those
two types of variation might come
together to make a locus or a location
in the dna particularly heterozygous or
diverse
we also wanted to observe if there were
any particular trends in the data
whether certain loci were more
heterozygous using a sequence based
approach and we performed a variety of
population genetic tests to ensure that
the data
were conforming to our expectations and
could be utilized in a forensic setting
we also wanted to identify any
shortcomings or limitations that could
be problematic for other research groups
but ultimately we wanted to just
generate a compendium of data that could
be used
by the forensic community as we move
forward into this new area
what we found in this really extensive
study was
four main trends first we saw an
increase in alleles for loci
when looking at only the repeat region
second we saw an increase in alleles for
certain loci looking only at the
flanking region so that region
outside of the repeat region third we
saw an increase in alleles in certain
loci
when combining the repeat and the
flanking regions
and then the fourth scenario was that we
saw no increase in alleles when
comparing to a traditional pcrce
approach or a length-based approach
showing you the data and how we
visualized it to fully understand
sequence variation we have a locus here
and you can see that everything is
color-coded
where each nucleotide has a different
color
but we could easily visualize any trends
or any snip variation that might be
present in the data
any black dots are deletions or missing
data
in that particular string sequence if we
zoom
in you can see in the orange box we have
the flanking region
and then at the top you have that repeat
region start
and you can see in that first repeat for
this particular locus
there's quite a bit of sequence
diversity
present and this sequence diversity has
been characterized
in the literature and so it wasn't
uncommon to observe it
but essentially tabulating the data in
this way
allowed for easy recognition of sequence
variations that we could best
understand each locus that we were
studying
what this study really revealed and why
we thought it was very significant to
share with the forensic community
is that there's a substantial gain in
information using a sequence based
approach
so you can see here the y chromosome the
x chromosome
and the autosomal strs all showed
an extensive gain in information using
sequence-based alleles
demonstrated in orange over length-based
alleles demonstrated in purple
focusing in on d9s one one two two
i really want to point out how
significantly impactful
sequence variation can be so we're going
to focus
in on the purple bar which is the allele
12.
zooming in you can see that there are
three different
alleles sequence based alleles
represented for the length-based allele
12.
the motif defined in the middle is
referring simply to that repeat region
and if you shift your attention to the
motif with flanking region sequences
you can see that highlighted in red and
highlighted in yellow
is the uniqueness of adding in that
flanking region information
so we went from one length based allele
12
to now three sequence based allele
12.
breaking this down for you the 12
length based allele will present as a
peak single peak
12 on an electro ferrogram however if
you look at the sequence you can see
that there's quite a bit of variability
looking only at the repeat region you
have two unique alleles
so the tag 12 or you have the
tag1tc ga1
tag10 and then you gain an additional
allele when you add in that flanking
region information
so this is an example of a locus that
when using both the repeat
and the flanking region information you
have a substantial gain in the total
number of alleles present
what's interesting is that looking at
the totality of the d9 locus we went
from
eight length-based alleles to 17
sequence-based alleles so that's a
drastic improvement in the overall power
of discrimination of those alleles at
that locus
visualizing what i just explained and
going back to that initial
image of sequence variation from the
beginning of my talk you can see here
where that variability falls within the
locus
so typically that snip is found at the
beginning of the repeat region
so it's highlighted in blue and you can
see it with the purple arrow
and that flanking region variation is
characterized by the orange arrow and
does have that db snip record associated
with it
meaning that it has been observed by
other groups
so what can happen when you only look at
the repeat region because
we spend all of this time really
focusing on characterizing alleles
based on their repeat region repeat
region composition
remembering that pcr ce
captures that entire amplicon so those
primers are set outside of the repeat
region capturing flanking region
information on either side of the repeat
even though we don't report it that way
we're still capturing that information
and changes in the flanking region will
impact the
actual length-based allele call if
there's an insertion a deletion
etc when we think about using mps and if
we only focus on the repeat region we're
potentially losing that
important information that's captured
and
quantified in the flanking region so
as we move forward using an mps based
approach it's very important to be
consistent with our pcrce methods
of looking at the entire amplicon
and defining both the repeat and the
flanking region
in terms of what the totality of allele
composition
is so just a couple of examples to
really reinforce this point
looking at d7 if you look at the repeat
region
allele 11 by length
only the mps software so in this case we
use the forensic universal analysis
software
reports only tatc 11.
however when doing concordant studies
with pcrce we found that it was at 10.3
and only in looking at the flanking
region information
were we able to capture a deletion in
the five prime
flank in order to explain this
microvariant or the 10.3 allele
designation
so again just reinforcing the value of
looking at the totality of information
captured
another example looking at d22 the 15
allele
the forensic software denoted just the
repeat region calling it a 15
whereas concordance data with capillary
electrophoresis and then using our
in-house tools
demonstrated that it was actually a 15.1
because of an insertion in the five
prime flank
of the amplicon so again just
stressing the value and importance of
looking at the totality of the amplicon
information
as i come to a close i want to just
bring your attention to the population
genetic consequences of using an
mps-based approach
really we're gaining so much information
in terms of the diversity of alleles
using an nps based approach but it will
also
strengthen our statistical support for
our profiles in terms of the rarity
of particular alleles and then the
rarity of the overall profile
and then looking at population specific
differences and inferring potential
ancestral information
from the unique sequences or the
the rare alleles that we're capturing in
actual casework so here i presented just
looking at the
overall random match probability of the
autosomal loci
from a length versus a sequence based
approach and you can see that there are
multifold differences
within each of our four populations
using either approach
taking that a step further there are
obvious markers that
either drastically increase the
diversity
of a dna profile and have a significant
impact on the rarity
of that profile and therefore impact the
random match probability and there are
other
loci where we learned didn't have any
real advantage using a sequence based
approach
and so they didn't significantly change
the power of discrimination
for their alleles in a dna profile and
those are highlighted here
so for a sequence sequence-based
improvement
you have certain alleles highlighted in
green that
are really going to take your dna
profile to the next level in terms of
power of discrimination
and then highlighted in red
where there is no significant
gain in information using those loci
because their length-based designations
seem to be
sufficiently uh powerful or
sufficiently useful for inferring
the rarity of those alleles
some final thoughts just pulling
all of this information together we know
that
using a length-based approach pcrce is a
robust way to generate a forensic dna
profile
however as we continue to push the
boundaries of
our sequence-based research it's very
important to keep in mind that a
sequence based approach does offer
significant promise
and potential for advancement in our
field of forensic genetics
looking at the overall improvement of
diversity or variation at particular
loci
in the study that i talked about in this
presentation we saw an increase in 644
alleles using a sequence based approach
and that is extremely significant
that just speaks to how much information
that we're not capturing using pcr
ce of those 400 were novel
meaning that they were never yet or they
were never before characterized in the
literature so that was a really
wonderful learning opportunity for our
group to really understand
the amount of diversity that hasn't yet
been
captured in the forensic genetic
research
and then finally it allowed us to
identify that certain loci
aren't substantially more powerful
using a sequence based approach and that
potentially we have the opportunity to
explore
new loci that might better aid us
in our complex interpretations moving
forward
but as the literature has supported
there have been continued efforts to
characterize
our forensic loci using a sequence based
approach
and there is a compendium of data
including the star seek
database housed by the national
institute of standards and technology
available to really understand the
sequence diversity in our loci
a great um publication that highlights
what i discussed
in today's talk um came out in 2016.
so please check out that publication if
you're interested in learning more about
exactly what our study entailed and
just to provide you with a variety of
resources in better understanding
sequence diversity
and i'd just like to thank my team
at the university of north texas health
science center
where i completed my doctoral studies
and did
the totality of the data presented in
this talk
as well as illumina and the national
institute of justice who supported this
research
if you have any questions please feel
free to reach out to me i am
again at the university of toronto
mississauga
um working in the forensic science
program and i'm very happy to talk more
about
str sequence variation forensic genetics
or forensic biology in general
thank you